[Music]
hey what's up guys I'm Kay Bhd here back
with another video in the YouTube tips
video series so if you like this video
idea or this series idea give it a
thumbs up as I really does help me know
which series you want me to keep going
on and I'll keep making videos if you
like this video so either way this is
going to be an episode on getting
inspired sort of inspiration and getting
video ideas making better videos and
this is also gonna be one of those sort
of less edited videos so just hopefully
you like that as well so the first thing
the question that I get the most often
is yeah how do you make better videos
now I might not be the person to tell
you like how to make a better video
because different is good is different
for everyone so John for Lakers might
tell you one thing and mystery guitar
man might tell you another thing and I
might tell you a totally different thing
and I it's it's really all up to you so
when I was thinking about this you know
how to make better videos I was really
thinking when I try to make better
videos I try to make videos that are
better to me that I would actually want
to watch so you can even use this one
you're thinking of ideas for videos to
do later think of what you would want to
see in your subscription box like if I
was browsing YouTube right now and I'm
just want to search for a random tech
video what do I want to see what I want
to see someone talk about something or
what I want to see someone explain
something that's what I would end up
making a video about cuz I don't see it
on YouTube and I want it to be there and
I will put it on YouTube and that's
that's just one of the little things
that I think about but here's a tip an
actual tip because this is the youtube
tips video series so you've made a video
and you finished creating it you've
produced it exported it whatever it's
sitting there on your desktop maybe
you've watched it a few times let it sit
there shut down your laptop go to sleep
and sit on it for one day a whole entire
day sleep on it and then wake up the
next day do your thing and then come
back to that video and watch the video
again and you will find so many things
that you would rather have different
about that video I swear I do this all
the time I'd make a review video keep
the project file so you can actually go
can change it and you might notice like
an awkward pause in the audio or you
might have wanted to say something
differently and you can go back and
actually do that so it's like you've had
a video up and you want to go back take
it down and change it that's what I
would say so actually sleep on it and
let me know if you try this because it
actually worked for me I found a lot of
my videos changed a lot just from doing
this having a video concept in your head
and making it a reality can really
evolve a lot when you sleep on it so
overall I'd say when you're trying to
make better videos I know this very
general tip but yet try to make videos
that are better to you so you know watch
the video you're trying to make a funny
video try to make yourself laugh if
you're trying to make a really
informative video do a lot of research
put things in the video that you didn't
know before you decided to start
researching that is what you want to try
to do and make a video that you think is
good and then chances are it's a good
video so yep that's basically what I got
for you guys today just a quick little
video letting you guys know an answer to
a very frequently asked question I guess
so again if you like the YouTube tips
video series just give this video a
thumbs up and I'll probably know how
that you guys like it and I'll also be
advancing some other series as well in
the near future as you guys already know
either way thanks for watching this
video and I'll talk to you guys later
peace
[Music]
you